what John did so well if he kind of  treated it as two very different movies  the high school side of things he just  tried to make it as authentic as  possible and that's what I think is so  great about him making his cast so  diverse well I think what was cool about  this movie is like it really didn't feel  like a superhero shooting it it just  kind of felt like a awkward dry humor  coming-of-age comedy kind of thing it's  really like a modern high school and it  really feels like a grounded high school  that would be in Queens so it's  definitely a cool dynamic to see a high  school students also be a superhero at  the same time hahaha  we're making fun of each other and  joking around and like I think that a  hundred percent translated you know into  what you see on camera which is really a  whole bunch of kids but it's like living  life yeah what we really is a group we  bond yeah we so long yeah don't wanna  leave even a part of it come on true  soon  you  you